where do you come from what were the
twists and turns in your family's
heritage that brought you to this point
it's a question that motivates millions
to use websites like ancestry.com every
day but that is just a start john
langler met a group that digs even
deeper
this is where the maze begins
palo verde library in henderson we're
not just names we're people the
detective work the search the quest we
did things we had life life happened
it's a regular meeting of the clark
county nevada genealogical society
helping answer questions since 1976.
real life
family tree building you have a lot of
other people who are working on the same
type puzzles
and pretty soon you just break down the
brick walls and you get to go further
even further pat salator is president i
love stories
i love
stories
she spent most of her adult life digging
into the lives of her adults and theirs
it's all about the dead people and
theirs it's the hunt
i love
making that score he was born in 1830.
there are census records archives
immigration logs from the turn of the
century many countries have an endless
supply of free information online the
church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints is an invaluable resource add
niger jordan and his wife amanda nelson
ah there's a great story with him for
salator genealogy is a lifelong hobby
blossomed into an obsession this is my
my database the threads of her family's
life crisscrossed the country salator
discovered murders stunned unknown
relatives ladies of the night and men
with and without honor
stunned things she never knew all
uncovered through painstaking research
everybody has a story
some people have more stories than
others and here in the library's
heritage room you can learn the real way
to piece your family together a lot of
it's the chase salator says you just
need to know how to look the truth of it
is is there are stories in your family
too
you just don't know them in the past
john langler live local now